Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. McDonald's has the gift that keeps giving. To Peter, your dog sitter, and Claire, who shovels your stairs. And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants, get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. This episode is brought to you by Dyson On Track.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。再次重申，网址是 therestishistory.com。麦当劳为您带来层层惊喜。致皮特，你的宠物保姆，还有克莱尔，帮你铲雪梯的人。还有你，当你在餐厅购买 25 美元的麦当劳礼品卡时，即可获赠一张免费巨无霸或麦香鸡的优惠券。详情请参阅参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。本期节目由戴森 On Track（Dyson On Track）赞助播出。
Dyson On Track headphones offer best-in-class noise cancellation and an enhanced sound range, making them perfect for enjoying music and podcasts. Get up to 55 hours of listening with active noise-cancelling-enabled, soft microfiber cushions engineered for comfort, and a range of colors and finishes. Dyson On Track, headphones remastered. Buy from DysonCanada.ca. With ANC on, performance may vary
戴森 On Track 耳机提供同类最佳的降噪功能和强化的音域，使其成为享受音乐和播客的完美之选。在开启主动降噪功能的情况下，可享受长达 55 小时的聆听体验，柔软的超细纤维耳垫专为舒适度而设计，并提供多种颜色和表面处理可供选择。戴森 On Track，耳机重塑。请在 DysonCanada.ca 购买。开启主动降噪功能时，性能可能会因环境条件和使用情况而异。
based on environmental conditions and usage. Accessories sold separately. The holidays are almost here, but Amazon still has last-minute deals. Like makeup for the beauty lover, electronics for the tech pro, A A victorious line of march had been prolonged above a thousand miles from the Rock of Gibraltar to the banks of the Loire. The repetition of an equal space would have carried the Saracens to the confines of Poland and the Highlands of Scotland. The Rhine is not more impassable than the Nile or Euphrates, and the Arabian fleet might have sailed without a naval combat into the mouth of the Thames.
配件另售。节日即将来临，但亚马逊仍有最后关头的优惠。比如送给美妆爱好者的化妆品，送给科技专家的电子产品，从直布罗陀岩石到卢瓦尔河岸，一场胜利的进军路线曾被延长了一千多英里。如果将这段相等的距离重复一次，萨拉森人就会到达波兰边境和苏格兰高地。莱茵河并不比尼罗河或幼发拉底河更难以跨越，阿拉伯舰队本可以在没有发生海战的情况下驶入泰晤士河口。
Perhaps the interpretation of the Quran would now be taught in the schools of Oxford, and her pulpits might demonstrate to a circumcised people the sanctity and truth of the revelation of Muhammad. From such calamities was Christendom delivered by the genius and fortune of one man. Charles, the illegitimate son of the elder Pepin, was content with the titles of mayor or duke of the Franks, but he deserved to become the father of a line of kings. That was Edward Gibbon in The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire, one of the most famous passages of historical prose ever written. He is describing the legacy of the Battle of Tor, which was fought on 10 October 732, or perhaps 733, nobody is entirely sure,
也许现在牛津的学校里会教授《古兰经》的解经学，而其布道坛可能会向一个受过割礼的民族证明穆罕默德启示的神圣与真理。基督教世界正是从这样的灾难中被一个人的天才与命运所拯救。查理，老丕平的私生子，满足于法兰克人的宫相或公爵称号，但他配得上成为一个国王世家的之父。以上是爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）在《罗马帝国衰亡史》（The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire）中的片段，这是有史以来最著名的历史散文段落之一。他正在描述图尔战役（Battle of Tours）的遗风，这场战役爆发于公元 732 年 10 月 10 日，或者可能是 733 年，谁也说不准，
between the Franks and what he called an invading force of Saracens. So Tom, great passage, great book, great subject. Just bring some of it alive for us. So who is Charles? Who are the Saracens? Where are we and what's going on? Okay. So we are still in our series on the Franks and Charles, who Gibbon in that passage is very careful to specify, is not a king, but a mayor or a duke of the Franks. He is perhaps the greatest of all the Frankish warlords since the time of Clovis, the king who founds the great kingdom of the Franks as the Roman Empire is falling. But we're now in the early eighth century and Charles will be known from the following century onwards as Charles Martel, the hammer.
交战双方是法兰克人与他所谓的萨拉森人入侵部队。那么，汤姆，好段落，好书，好主题。给我们把其中的一些情景还原一下。那么查理是谁？萨拉森人又是谁？我们现在在哪里，发生了什么？好的。所以我们仍然在关于法兰克人和查理的系列节目中，吉本在那个段落中非常小心地指明，他不是国王，而是法兰克人的宫相或公爵。自从克洛维——那个在罗马帝国衰亡之际建立法兰克伟大王国的国王——的时代以来，他或许是所有法兰克军阀中最伟大的一个。但我们现在处于八世纪初，而查理从下个世纪开始将被人们称为“铁锤”查理·马特（Charles Martel）。
So a tremendous name for a guy who has a very mailed fist. The Saracens are an army in the service of the Ameyad Caliphate. So that is the first great Arab empire, the first great empire of Islam. And this is why Gibbon is casting it as a peculiarly decisive clash. He's framing it as a battle between Christianity and Islam. And he's suggesting that had it gone the other way, had the Franks lost to the Saracens, to the Muslims, to the Arabs, then perhaps we might've seen the interpretation of the Quran taught in Oxford. And there's a bit of a joke here because Gibbon had been
对于一个铁腕人物来说，这是一个极其威风的名字。萨拉森人是效力于倭马亚哈里发国的一支军队。这就是第一个伟大的阿拉伯帝国，伊斯兰教的第一个伟大帝国。这就是为什么吉本把它描绘成一场具有特殊决定性意义的冲突。他将其定性为基督教与伊斯兰教之间的战役。他暗示，如果历史走向相反，如果法兰克人输给了萨拉森人、穆斯林、阿拉伯人，那么也许我们就会看到牛津大学里教授《古兰经》的阐释。这里其实有个小笑话，因为吉本曾是
a student at Oxford and had absolutely hated it. He despised all the dons who at the time were Anglican priests. And so I think he's slightly tweaking the noses of his old teachers and suggesting that they might have been circumcised followers of Muhammad. But it's obviously, it's not just a joke because Gibbon has a genius for, well, Byron referred to his solemn sneer. When he makes a joke, there's often a kind of very serious purpose and he's making a serious point here. He's saying this is one of the great decisive battles of world history.
牛津大学的学生，而且对那里恨之入骨。他鄙视所有的大学导师，他们当时都是英国国教的牧师。所以我认为他是在略微调侃他的老老师们，暗示他们本可能会成为穆罕默德受过割礼的追随者。但这显然不仅仅是个笑话，因为吉本有着某种天才，或者说拜伦曾提到过他的“严肃的冷笑”。当他开玩笑时，往往带有某种非常严肃的目的，他在这里阐述了一个严肃的观点。他说，这是世界历史上具有决定性的伟大战役之一。
And this is an argument that people made particularly in the 19th and early 20th century, isn't it? That the Battle of Tours, if it was 14732, was one of the genuinely pivotal moments when history might have gone differently, that had the Franks lost to the Saracens, then Islam, the advance of the Arab armies would have continued up into France and that the entire course of European and world history might have been different. In fact, all Europe might have fallen within the kind of Islamic world and people genuinely made that argument very vigorously, among them Adolf Hitler, right? Right. So most of the historians in the 19th and 20th century who are pushing this case,
这也是人们特别在 19 世纪和 20 世纪初提出的一个论点，不是吗？即图尔战役，如果是在公元 732 年，是一个真正关键的时刻，当时历史本可能走向不同的方向，如果法兰克人输给了萨拉森人，那么伊斯兰教、阿拉伯军队的推进就会一直持续到法国境内，整个欧洲和世界历史的进程可能就会完全不同。事实上，整个欧洲都可能落入某种伊斯兰世界之中，人们曾非常激烈地提出过这种论点，阿道夫·希特勒就是其中之一，对吧？没错。因此，19 世纪和 20 世纪绝大多数持这种看法的历史学家，
they see the possibility that Christian Europe might have become Muslim as a disaster. So Gibbon refers to it in that passage he read as a calamity. But one person, he said, who thought it was a great shame that the Franks had won was Adolf Hitler. And the reasons for this, he spelt it out in his table talk and I'll read it. Had Charles Martel not been victorious at Poitiers, he said, already you see the world had fallen into the hands of the Jews, so gutless a thing is Christianity. Then we should in all probability have been converted to Mohammedanism, that cult which glorifies the heroism and which opens up the seventh heaven to the bold warrior alone. Then the
他们将基督教欧洲可能变成穆斯林的这种可能性视为一场灾难。因此吉本在他所朗读的那个段落中称其为一场灾难。但是，他说有一个人认为法兰克人的胜利是一件大憾事，那就是阿道夫·希特勒。他把这其中的原因写在了他的《希特勒桌边谈话》（Table Talk）中，我来读一下。他说，如果查理·马特在普瓦捷没有取胜，那么你看，世界早就落入犹太人之手了，基督教就是这么个软弱无能的东西。那么我们极有可能已经皈依了伊斯兰教，那个崇拜英雄主义、并仅向勇敢的战士敞开第七重天的教派。那样的话，
Germanic races would have conquered the world. Christianity alone prevented them from doing so. Craigie. Because to Hitler, Christianity is a kind of weedy, wet religion that encourages peace. But this is not what the vast majority of historical scholars now think. Most agree now that the Battle of Tours was massively overblown. It was kind of a propaganda victory above all else, partly because the Arabs are not trying to launch a massive invasion of what was once called. It's a raid, one among many that they launch,
日耳曼民族就会征服世界。唯独基督教阻止了他们这样做。克雷吉（Craigie）。因为对希特勒来说，基督教是一种提倡和平的、软弱无力的宗教。但绝大多数历史学者现在可不这么认为。大多数人现在认为图尔战役被严重夸大了。它首先是一场宣传上的胜利，部分原因在于阿拉伯人当时并不是在试图对曾经被称为……的地方发动大规模入侵。这只是一次突袭，是他们发动的众多突袭中的一次，
and the consequence is not as great as is often thought. Will Barron Yes. So that's one argument that is, I would say is pretty much the consensus now among academics on the status of the Battle of Tor, that it's not an invasion, that it's a raid, also that it's not a clash between Christianity and Islam because no contemporary really seems to frame it as such, and also that in a way it owes more to faction fighting among various Frankish warlords of whom Charles Martel is one than it does to Muslim dreams of world conquest. But, you know, there are plenty of other scholars who do hold to the kind of Gibbonian view, and it's a debate that's been rumbling away now
其后果也并没有人们通常认为的那般重大。威廉·巴伦（Will Barron）没错。所以这是一个论点，我想说，这现在几乎是学术界对图尔战役地位的共识，即它不是一次入侵，而是一次突袭；其次，它也不是基督教与伊斯兰教之间的冲突，因为当时的任何同时代人似乎都没有将其定性为这种冲突；此外，在某种程度上，它更多地归因于查理·马特所属的各个法兰克军阀之间的派系斗争，而不是穆斯林征服世界的梦想。但是，你知道，还有很多其他学者仍然坚持吉本式的观点，这场争论已经持续了
for decades. And it is a debate that has kind of echoed beyond universities in a way that is unusual for debates about Frankish history. Because this, I would say in general, you know, the period that we've been discussing these centuries of Frankish history are among the most obscure in European history. It's not a period that people know a great deal amount, but the Battle of Tours does have cut through and there's an obvious reason for that, which is basically the kind of political context in Europe today and specifically the fact that over recent decades, the growth of the Muslim population in Europe has been considerable. And this particularly in France, so the ancient Frankish heartland, it has generated
数十年之久。而且这场争论在某种程度上已经超越了大学校园，其方式对于法兰克历史的争论来说是不寻常的。因为总的来说，我可以说，我们一直在讨论的法兰克历史的这些世纪，是欧洲历史上最晦涩难懂的时期之一。这不是人们了解很多的时期，但图尔战役确实产生了深远的影响，这有一个显而易见的原因，那就是欧洲当今的政治背景，具体而言，就是过去几十年来，欧洲穆斯林人口的大幅增长。这在法国尤甚——作为古代法兰克人的核心地带，它引发了
quite a far right reaction. But you know, not only in France, so in Britain, for instance, there are now Muslim scholars preaching the Quran in Oxford. And there are people in here, in Britain, as in France, as in other countries in Europe, who regard this with extreme hostility. And I think the implications of this for discussion of the Battle of Tours in far-right circles is, I mean, is unbelievably toxic. So you can see this in the way that it's been used by far-right groups. So as early as the 1970s in France, in the wake of the Algerian war, de Gaulle settlement of that and the growth of Algerian immigration into France, in the 70s, there was an anti-Algerian terrorist group, a far-right terrorist group, and it called itself the group Chalmatel.
相当激进的右翼反应。但你知道，不仅在法国，比如在英国，现在也有穆斯林学者在牛津宣讲《古兰经》。在英国、法国以及欧洲其他国家，都有人对此抱有极度的敌意。我认为这对于极右翼圈子里讨论图尔战役所产生的影响，简直是——可以说是毒性极大。因此，你可以从极右翼团体利用它的方式中看到这一点。早在 20 世纪 70 年代的法国，在阿尔及利亚战争之后、戴高乐对该问题的解决以及阿尔及利亚移民对法国人口增长的影响之下，70 年代出现了一个反阿尔及利亚的恐怖组织，一个极右翼恐怖组织，它自称为“查理·马特集团”（Group Charles Martel）。
So drawing its direct inspiration from the Frankish Duke who had won the battle of Tor. Then in 2015, after the Charlie Hebdo massacre, you know, so the publishers of the Styrical magazine in France who were kind of shot by an Islamist gunman, Jean-Marie Le Pen, who was leader of the National Front at the time, father of Marine Le Pen, there was this slogan, Je suis Charlie. So people saying, identifying themselves with the victims of the attack on Charlie Hebdo. But Jean-Marie Le Pen said, no, Je suis Charlie Martel. And perhaps the most brutal manifestation of the way in which the far right have identified with Charles Martel is that in 2019, people
因此，它直接从赢得图尔战役的法兰克公爵那里汲取灵感。然后是在 2015 年，《查理周刊》惨案发生之后，你知道的，法国那家讽刺杂志的出版商遭到了一名伊斯兰枪手的枪击；当时国民阵线的领导人、玛丽娜·勒庞的父亲让-玛丽·勒庞（Jean-Marie Le Pen），当时有一个口号是“我是查理”（Je suis Charlie）。人们以此表达自己对《查理周刊》袭击事件受害者的认同。但让-玛丽·勒庞却说：“不，我是查理·马特”（Je suis Charlie Martel）。也许极右翼认同查理·马特的最残酷的表现在于，在 2019 年，大家可能还记得，在偏偏是新西兰——这个距离法国地球另一端的地方——发生了一起由一名澳大利亚恐怖分子制造的恐怖袭击。他袭击了一座清真寺和基督城的伊斯兰中心，杀害了 51 人。而在他的枪上，他就刻着查理·马特的名字。所以你可以看到，对于学者们来说，要将这一点从他们的研究中抹去是非常困难的，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，这有点——是的，当然。我的确认为，当你阅读学者们关于图尔战役的论述时，那些说“哦，这是一个极其重要的时刻，这是世界文明的一个关键时刻，是一场改变一切的战役”的学者，他们往往都带有非常特定的政治倾向。
may remember there was a terrorist attack in New Zealand of all places, so the opposite end of the world from France done by an Australian terrorist. And he attacked a mosque and an Islamic center in Christchurch, killed 51 people. And on his gun, he had inscribed the name of Charles Martel. So you can see that for academics, this is very difficult, I think, to kind of banish this from what they're doing. Wouldn't you say? I mean, it's kind of- Yeah, of course. I do think when you read an academic on the Battle of Tours, academics who say, oh, it's a terribly important moment, it's a pivotal moment in world civilisation, a battle that changed everything. They always do tend to be of a very particular political persuasion.
我想同样地，你也可以说，那些认为这并不重要、只是一场微不足道边境小冲突的人，往往也带有特定的政治倾向，这简单来说就是：我认为很难将这场战役的讨论从当前的政治背景中剥离出来。因此，正如右翼有人说这是对欧洲的拯救一样；而在另一方面，在左翼，你有时会有一种感觉：基本上法兰克人没有向入侵者投降，这本身就是法兰克人的一种种族主义行为。我认为这反映出一个事实：也许在我们迄今为止在《历史的余烬》中讨论过的所有战役中，这场战役在政治上是最敏感的。
I think equally you could say that those who say that it's unimportant, that it's a minor border skirmish, also tend to be of a particular political persuasion, which is simply to say that it is difficult, I think, to remove discussions of this battle from current political contexts. So just as there are people on the right who say this was the saving of Europe. So on the other hands on the left, you occasionally, you will get the sense that basically it was kind of racist of the Franks not to have surrendered to the invaders at all. And I think it reflects the fact that maybe of all the battles we've discussed so far on the rest is history, this is politically the most sensitive of the lot.
因此，我认为在我们深入探讨战役本身的细节之前，非常有必要详细解释一下这里所发生事情的背景。好了。那么，让我们从阿拉伯人开始讲起。吉本称他们为萨拉森人，这个词现在已经不常听到了。但事实上他们并不是真正的阿拉伯人，对吧？这支军队的大多数人几乎可以肯定是来自北非的柏柏尔人，来自我们曾经称之为毛里塔尼亚的地方，或者其中很多人可能来自西班牙。所以他们不是阿拉伯人。事实上，他们甚至是穆斯林吗？因为
So that's why I think before we get into the details of the battle itself, it's really important to explain the context for what is going on here in some detail. All right. Well, let's start with the Arabs. So Gibbon calls them Saracens, which is not a word that you often hear these days. But actually they're not really Arabs, are they? Most of that army are almost certainly Berbers from North Africa, from what we'd once have called Mauritania, or probably a lot of them from Spain. So they're not Arabs. And actually, are they even Muslims? Because
当然，在这一点上，伊斯兰教在某种程度上仍然处于形成的过程中，不是吗？是的，正如你所说的那样，由于种种原因，很难用哪个词来准确描述这些入侵者。我的意思是，军队中的柏柏尔人——很可能是大多数——其中许多人对伊斯兰教是什么只有最模糊的概念。正如你所说，伊斯兰教本身在这个时候仍然处于演变的过程中。此时的伊斯兰教最好被视为一种特许经营系统；
of course, at this point, Islam is still in the process of kind of being formed, isn't it, to some degree? Yeah, it's really difficult to know what word to use to describe these invaders for the reasons that you said. I mean, and certainly the Berbers in the army, probably the majority, I mean, loads of them would have had only the haziest sense of what Islam was. And as you say, Islam itself is still in the process of evolution at this point. Islam at this point is best thought of as a kind of franchising system. So groups of people beyond the kind of the heartlands of the Umayyad Empire back in Syria
超越了位于叙利亚、伊拉克和阿拉伯半岛的倭马亚帝国核心地带的群体，获得了巴格达哈里发的授权，可以组建他们自己的武装队伍，他们自己的集团。本质上，哈里发给予这些人群的授权是走出去，将穆罕默德的启示宣扬到世界的尽头。但许多人之所以接受这一点，不一定是因为他们热切地致力于传播《古兰经》的信息。而是因为他们想出去抢夺东西、掠夺修道院、城镇等等。这是一支袭扰队，我想，这在某种程度上与一个类似时期的斯堪的纳维亚袭扰队并没有太大区别。
and Iraq and Arabia are licensed by the caliph in Baghdad to form their own kind of posses, their own groups. And essentially the license that the caliph is giving these groups of people is to go out and proclaim the revelations of Muhammad to the limits that the caliph is giving these groups of people is to go out and proclaim the revelations of Muhammad to the limits of the world. But the reason that lots of people kind of buy into this isn't necessarily because they are kind of passionately committed to spreading the message of the Quran. It's because they want to go out and grab stuff and strip and loot monasteries and towns or whatever. It's a raiding party and not, I guess, totally unlike Scandinavian raiding party in a, you know, not massively dissimilar period.
我想你是对的。同样，这与维京时期有相似之处，这可能是我们在本集节目后面会谈到的话题。因此，在七世纪末到八世纪的进程中，你所拥有的是名义上是穆斯林的武装战帮，从埃及沿着北非海岸一直向西蔓延，直到毛里塔尼亚。然后在公元 711 年，发生了一次跨越直布罗陀海峡的试探性突袭；因此，一帮柏柏尔人、阿拉伯人、穆斯林——无论你想怎么称呼他们——的武装战帮在西班牙登陆，并取得了惊人的成功。所以他们遇到了西哥特国王。这就是那个曾将布伦希尔德交给法兰克人的王国，而他们将国王及其军队彻底消灭了。他们继续前进，攻占了位于西班牙中部的托莱多，那是西哥特人的主要城市。这是一场巨大的胜利。这是一场类似于埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernán Cortés）式的胜利，推翻了一个庞大而富裕的帝国。送回叙利亚的战利品如此之多，以至于在叙利亚的倭马亚人眼中，西班牙成了一片奇迹之地。那是一个有会说话的雕像的地方，那里的城市完全由黄铜建造，到处都是宝藏，而且还充满了奴隶。因此，一拨多达 30,000 名西哥特奴隶的庞大队伍被送回了大马士革。同样，这被视为一件非同寻常的事。因此，在这场胜利之后，入侵者继续向前推进也就不足为奇了。到公元 719 年，也就是他们在直布罗陀登陆仅仅八年后，入侵者已经穿过了比利牛斯山脉，并在 720 年攻占了伟大的城市纳博讷（Narbonne）——当时在高卢南部海岸还残留着一小条西哥特领土。纳博讷落入入侵者之手，随后他们向四处扩散，征服了高卢南部其余的西哥特据点。因此，贝济耶（Béziers）、阿德（Agde）、尼姆（Nîmes），全都沦陷了。基本上，除了西班牙北部地区之外，西哥特王国的几乎全部领土在短短十年内都落入了这些入侵者手中。我的意思是，这是一项惊人的征服壮举。
I think you're right. And again, that's kind of parallels with this and the Viking period is something we might come to kind of later on in the episode. And so what you have going over the course of the late seventh, going into the eighth centuries is war bands who are kind of nominally Muslim, spreading westwards from Egypt along the northern coast of Africa all the way to Mauritania. And then in 711, there's a kind of exploratory raid across the Straits of Gibraltar. So a war band of Berbers, of Arabs, of Muslims, wherever you want to call them, they land in Spain and they have spectacular success. So they meet the king of the Visigoths. This is the kingdom that
那么，再往那边就是法兰克人的土地，也就是我们上周讨论过的王国。它由墨洛温王朝统治。我们说到克洛泰尔二世（Clothar II）赢得了对布伦希尔德的胜利，他基本上对曾经属于罗马高卢的整个领土拥有了君主统治权。因此，所有不同的王国现在都承认他是它们的——或者说各个不同的部分现在都承认他是它们的国王。但我读到过，墨洛温王朝衰落的种子其实早就已经埋下了。它就包含在这一巨大的成功之中。所以，正如你所说，克洛泰尔二世将曾经属于罗马高卢的各个不同部分拼凑在了一起。因此，纽斯特利亚（Neustria）——紧邻海峡的王国，奥斯特拉西亚（Austrasia）——跨越莱茵河深入德国境内的王国东部地区，
had given the Franks Brunhilde and wipes the king and his army out. They go on, they capture Toledo, which is in the centre of Spain, the main Visigothic city. And it's a spectacular victory. It's a kind of Hernán Cortés type victory, the overthrow of a great and wealthy empire. And the loot that gets sent back to Syria is so overwhelming that Spain comes to seem to the eyes of the Ameyads back in Syria, a kind of land of wonders. It's a place of talking statues where cities are fashioned entirely out of brass, just full of treasure and also full of slaves. So a massive coffle of 30,000 Visigothic slaves are sent back to Damascus. And again, this is seen as being something extraordinary. And so it's not surprising in the wake of
勃艮第（Burgundy）——东南部地区，以及阿基坦（Aquitaine）——西南部地区。克洛泰尔二世设法统治了所有这些地区。但最终这对墨洛温王朝不利的原因是，事实证明，对于克洛泰尔二世和他的儿子兼继承人达戈贝尔特（Dagobert）来说，这个王国实在是太大了。因此，克洛泰尔最终不得不做的是，基本上把他的儿子们派出去作为某种藩王进行统治。其中一个去了阿基坦，完全是个废柴。一位编年史家将其贬为“头脑简单”。达戈贝尔特，克洛泰尔的儿子，被派去统治奥斯特拉西亚。他稍微能干一点。但当他到达时，他年轻、缺乏经验。这意味着他在我们已经见过的奥斯特拉西亚两位最强权的人物手中非常容易受到摆布。我们在上一集的结尾见过他们，因为这是一位名叫丕平（Pepin）的领主和一位名叫阿努尔夫（Arnulf）的主教。
this success that the invaders press onwards. And by 719, so that's just eight years after they'd landed in Gibraltar, the invaders have crossed the Pyrenees and in 720 they capture the great city of Narbonne, which there's still a kind of tiny strip of Visigothic territory on the coast of southern Gaul. Narbonne falls to the invaders and then they fan out to conquer the remaining Visigothic strongholds in southern Gaul. So Bezier, Agde, Nîmes, they all fall and essentially pretty much the whole of the Visigothic strongholds in southern Gaul, so Béziers, Agde, Nimes, they all fall. And essentially pretty much the whole of the Visigothic kingdom, with the exception of kind of the northern reaches of Spain, have fallen in the space of basically a decade
这些人就是联合起来推翻布伦希尔德的人。他们背叛了她。因此她最终被克洛泰尔俘虏，并受到了极其残酷的处刑。因此，阿努尔夫作为年轻的达戈贝尔特最重要的谋士为他服务，而丕平则时有时无地为他服务。有时他隐退，有时他又复出，但他基本上不仅是奥斯特拉西亚的首席显贵，也是该王国的首席官员。他在拉丁语中的身份是 meor domus，你知道的，你可以把它英语化为 major domo，他是宫相，他是首席官员。而这些官员有着非常非常大的野心。正如墨洛温王国学者伊茨哈克·亨（Yitzhak Hen）所描述的那样：“站在墨洛温政体最重要枢纽上的宫相们是如此强大、雄心勃勃且坚决果断。”我想传统上，从克洛维时代开始，这些 maores（即宫相，我们这么称呼他们吧）的作用是充当国王与地方显贵、地方领主之间的调解人。但丕平是如此精干、如此强大，而达戈贝尔特又是如此缺乏经验和年轻，以至于丕平能够让自己超越这一角色，实际上成为了王位背后的权臣。
to these invaders. I mean, it's a spectacular feat of conquest. So now beyond that is the land of the Franks and that's the kingdom we talked about last week. It's ruled by the Merovingian dynasty. We left it with Clothar II, he's won his victory over Brunhilde and he's basically got a monarchy over the whole of what was once the Roman territory of Gaul. So all the different kingdoms are now acknowledging him as their, all the different bits rather, are now acknowledging him as their king. But I read that the seeds of the Merovingian's downfall had already been sown. It's contained in this very success. So yes, as you say, Clothar II had patched together
而丕平的成就在于建立了一个实际上类似于墨洛温王朝的影子王朝。因此，丕平的女儿后来嫁给了首席顾问、主教阿努尔夫的儿子。这对夫妇生下一个儿子，在各方面都绝对是其祖父的翻版。因此，他像他的祖父一样也叫丕平。编年史家为了将他与他的祖父区分开来，称他为“椎髻的丕平”（Pepin of Herstal）。他在 680 年成为了奥斯特拉西亚的宫相。我的意思是，他不仅是王位背后的权臣，他还把王位笼罩在自己的阴影之下。他是一个绝对专横的人物，而他之所以能做到这一点，是因为对于墨洛温家族来说，发生了一系列非常不幸的客观情况：接连不断的小孩子继承了王位，然后夭折，又由另一个小孩子继位。（如果他们能活到成年，也完全是废物。）因此，在椎髻的丕平——这位权倾朝野的大宫相——的阴影下，墨洛温国王实际上被沦为一个无足轻重的傀儡。到椎髻的丕平于 714 年去世时，他不仅让自己成为了奥斯特拉西亚（他是这里的宫相）的主人，还成为了纽斯特利亚、北部勃艮第的主人，并且他一直在向东推进。在他的领导下，法兰克人开始征服今天属于荷兰和德国中部的大片土地。椎髻的丕平不再满足于仅仅拥有宫相的头衔。他想要更多。因此，他给自己加了一个绝对辉煌的头衔：Dux et Princeps Francorum，即法兰克人的公爵与亲王。他确立了这个头衔，并使其世袭，就好像这是一种王权一样。而他的儿子——椎髻的丕平的儿子——就是查理·马特。
all the various parts of what had been Roman Gaul. So, Neustria, which is the kingdom kind of abutting the channel, Austrasia, which is the kind of the eastern reaches of the kingdom stretching beyond the Rhine deep into Germany Austrasia, which is the kind of the eastern reaches of the kingdom, stretching beyond the Rhine, deep into Germany. Burgundy, which is the kind of the southeast, and Aquitaine, which is the southwest. And Clothar II has managed to rule them all. But the reason why this ultimately is not good for the Merovingian dynasty is that basically it's too large, it turns out, for Clothar II second and his son and heir Dagoburt to rule. So what Clothar ends up having to do is to essentially send his sons out to rule as kind
好，所以查理·马特，尽管还有一个墨洛温国王，我们其实不用太担心他，他叫提乌德里克四世（Theodoric IV）。对，他是个废柴。但查理·马特是曾经被称为奥斯特拉西亚、纽斯特利亚、勃艮第等大片地区的统治者。但这留下了法国东南部的另一个地方，那就是阿基坦。而阿基坦是对抗查理·马特的，是这样吗？这将对我们讲述图尔战役的故事非常重要。阿基坦有一位名叫奥多（Odo）的公爵，我们就叫他奥多吧。那么跟我讲讲他吧。他是一个饱经风霜、经验丰富的人。他身经百战、狡猾多端，绝对不想向查理·马特的统治屈服。他实际上希望保持某种程度的独立。他是法兰克人，但他能够借助当地曾经存在的罗马行省的古老传统。因此，他希望维护的是一种独立性。当他只需要应付查理·马特和卢瓦尔河以北的法兰克人时，这倒还好。奥多的噩梦是萨拉森人（正如他所称呼的那样）的到来。他被这两个可怕的敌人夹在了中间。因此，他北面有法兰克王国，南面则是从南方骑马杀来的萨拉森人。因此，毫无疑问，奥多试图让这两个具有威胁性的敌人互相牵制。因此，毫无疑问，奥多试图让这两个具有威胁性的敌人互相牵制。所以在 721 年，倭马亚军队完成了对西哥特高卢地区的征服，
of sub-kings. So one goes off to Aquitaine, he's absolutely useless. A chronicler dismisses him as simple-minded. Dagoburt, Clothar's son, he's sent off to rule Australia. He's slightly more efficient. But when he arrives, he's young, he's inexperienced. And this means that he is very malleable in the hands of the two greatest men in Australia, who we have already met. We met them at the end of the previous episode, because these are a lord called Pepin and a bishop called Arnulf.
然后他们将注意力转向了阿基坦。在 721 年的春天，他们围攻了阿基坦的大城市图卢兹（Toulouse）。奥多向查理·马特求助，他说：“听着，我们大家都是法兰克人。你能来帮帮我吗？这简直是个噩梦。”而查理·马特非但没有为基督教事业挺身而出，反而说：“不，我没兴趣。你自己看着办吧。”所以可怜的奥多不得不基本上靠自己的力量来应对这场危机。
And these are the guys who had got together to overthrow Brunhilde. They'd betrayed her. And so she'd ended up being captured by Clothar and then very horribly executed. So Arnulf serves the young Daggerbert as his kind of preeminent counselor and Pepin serves him kind of off and on. Sometimes he retires, sometimes he comes back, but he is basically not just the kind of the leading magnate in Australia, but he is also the leading official in that kingdom. And his status is in Latin, me or domus, which you know, you could anglicize that to be major
他非常非常有效地做到了这一点，因为他集结了军队。他悄悄地接近了围攻图卢兹周围的阿拉伯军队，打了他们一个措手不及，并将其彻底消灭。这是倭马亚军队在欧洲遭受的第一次重大失败。奥多大获全胜。他给教皇写了一封信，说：“我真是太棒了。我杀死了 375,000 名萨拉森人”，这可能有些夸大其词。但显然这是一场至关重要的胜利。目前，他将阿基坦从入侵中拯救了出来。他不仅为自己，也为北方土地上的查理·马特赢得了一段喘息的时间，好让他们基本上为
domo, his mayor, he's the leading official. And these officials are very, very ambitious. So powerful, ambitious and resolute were the mayores who stood at the most important junctions of Merovingian polity. So that's how Yitzhak Hen, scholar of the Merovingian kingdom, describes them. And I guess traditionally, so going back to the time of Clovis, the role of these maores, these mayors, let's call them that, was to kind of mediate between the king and the local magnates, the local lords. But Pepin is so able, so powerful, Daggerbert is so kind of inexperienced and young that Pepin is able to make himself into something more than that, effectively the power behind the throne.
他们知道将要来临的风暴做准备。他们知道战争的风暴正在聚集，因此两人都在为即将到来的入侵做准备。他们知道这一点，因为尽管倭马亚人在图卢兹城墙前被击败了，但他们并没有被驱逐出高卢。他们一直在不断地向北发动突袭，甚至远至勃艮第，对吧？没错。所以勃艮第的欧坦（Autun）——布伦希尔德在其摄政的最后几年里将其定为首都的一座非常美丽的古罗马城市——遭到了洗劫和焚烧。许多其他城镇也是如此，特别是修道院。你把阿拉伯人的突袭比作维京人的突袭是有同样原因的。他们以修道院为目标，因为那里装满了可以被劫掠走的财富。所以这看起来真的很糟糕。因此，奥多的策略是试图拉拢阿拉伯军阀并与他们结盟。他成功地与一个名叫乌斯曼（Uthman）的柏柏尔军阀达成了这一点，后者被委任指挥现在的加泰罗尼亚地区。对倭马亚人来说，这是一个边境地区、边界地区。而奥多希望稳定他的南部边境，乌斯曼则希望将加泰罗尼亚开辟为
And Pepin's achievement is to set up what effectively is a kind of shadow dynasty to the Merovingian dynasty. So Pepin's daughter goes on to marry the son of Arnof, the bishop, who's the kind of the chief advisor. And this couple, they have a son who is absolutely kind of in every sense, a chip off the old block. So he, like his grandfather, is also called Pepin. So he's called Pepin of hairstyle by the chroniclers to distinguish him from his grandfather. He becomes the mayor of Australia in 680. And I mean, he's not just the power behind the throne, he puts the throne in his shadow. He is an absolutely domineering figure and he's able to do that because for the Mirror of Injuns, very unfortunate series of circumstances, there is a succession of kind of children who succeed to the throne,
而矮子丕平的成就，是建立了一个实际上类似于墨洛温王朝的影子王朝。因此，丕平的女儿嫁给了主教阿诺夫的儿子，后者可以说是首席谋臣。这对夫妇生了一个儿子，在各方面都完全继承了祖辈的遗风。因此，他像他的祖父一样也被称为丕平。为了将他与祖父区分开来，编年史家称他为赫斯塔尔的丕平。他在680年成为了奥斯特拉西亚的宫相。我的意思是，他不仅仅是王权背后的操纵者，他把王权都笼罩在自己的阴影之下。他是一个绝对专横的人物，他之所以能够做到这一点，是因为对于墨洛温家族来说，有一系列非常不幸的环境，导致王位由一连串的孩子继承，
die, succeeded by another child. You know, if they grow to adulthood, they're absolutely useless. And so in the shadow of Pepin of Herstal, this great overweening mayor, the Merovingian king is reduced effectively to a kind of cipher. And by the time that Pepin of Herstal dies in 714, he's made himself the master not just of Austrasia where he's the mayor, but also of Neustria, that northern kingdom of Burgundy, and he's also been pushing eastwards. So under his leadership, the Franks have begun conquering swathes of what today are the Netherlands and central Germany. And Pepin of Herstal is no longer content just with the title of mayor. He wants something more. And so he has given himself an absolutely brilliant title, Dux et Princeps Francorum,
一个独立的封地。他想凭自己的力量进行统治，而不是屈从于托莱多的倭马亚总督。这项同盟于 730 年签署，为了巩固同盟，奥多将自己的女儿嫁给了乌斯曼。我能打断你一下吗？许多听众可能会觉得这非常有趣，因为这显然颠覆了那种文明冲突论，即人们是有意识地参与文明冲突的观点，因为在这里，你看到了一个基督教与——从某种竖向的层面来看——穆斯林的同盟，以及伴随而来的联姻。因此，他们这样做时，并没有感到自己跨越了某种巨大的意识形态鸿沟。
the Duke and the Prince of the Franks. And he has established this title, as though it was a kind of kingship, as hereditary. And his son, Pepin of Herstal's son, is Charles Martel. Right, so Charles Martel, although there is a Merovingian king, we don't need to really worry too much about him, he's called Theodoric IV. Yeah, he's useless. But Charles Martel, although there is a Merovingian king, we don't need to really worry too much about him, he's called Theodoric IV. Yeah, he's useless. But Charles Martel is the ruler of huge swathes of what was once called, Austrasia, Neustadt, Burgundy and so on. But that leaves one other place in the south east of France, which is Aquitaine.
没有，因为对奥多和乌斯曼这两个人来说，最重要的是权力政治。这比任何所谓伟大的文明冲突感要重要得多。起初，这似乎起作用了。阿基坦边境沿线保持了稳定。乌斯曼能够确立自己的独立地位，但麻烦正在酝酿。战争的风暴继续聚集，因为在托莱多，听到这个同盟的消息就像喝了一杯凉透的恶心呕吐物一样让人难受。不幸的是，对于乌斯曼和奥多来说，托莱多的总督是一位新总督，他极为能干，同时也极为虔诚。这个人名叫阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼·加菲基（Abd al-Rahman al-Ghafiqi）。他来自阿拉伯半岛。他来自红海。他来自伊斯兰教的核心地带。与西班牙的大多数人相比，他可能对当时正在成型的伊斯兰教有着更深刻的掌控，并且他绝不准备容忍这种事。因此，他的反应是毁灭性的。731 年，他入侵加泰罗尼亚。他击败了乌斯曼，将其杀死，俘虏了乌斯曼的妻子（即奥多的女儿），并把她打发到大马士革，住在哈里发的后宫里。所以，这对奥多来说是个坏消息，对奥多的女儿来说大概也是如此。你刚才说这并没有真正体现出某种文明冲突在上演。而正当阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼在加泰罗尼亚这样做的时候，
And Aquitaine stands against Charles Martel, is that right? And this is going to be very important for our story of the Battle of Tor. So Aquitaine has got a duke called Odo, let's call him Odo. So tell me about him. He's a very grizzled experience bloke. He is battle hardened, cunning and absolutely does not want to submit to the rule of Charles Martel. He wants to effectively maintain his kind of independence. He's Frankish, but he's able to draw on the kind of the ancient traditions of the Roman province that had been there. So it's a kind of independence that he wants to uphold. And this has been fine while he's only had to deal with Charles
查理·马特显然没有在帮基督教的忙，因为他已经跨过了卢瓦尔河，正利用奥多因同盟破裂而陷入绝望的状态，对阿基坦发动了进攻，并把大量的战利品向北运往卢瓦尔河。所以这完全没有帮上忙。随后在第二年的春天，阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼入侵了阿基坦。他一路向北横扫加斯科尼（Gascony），兵临波尔多（Bordeaux），将其攻陷并洗劫。奥多一直在疯狂地召集人马以试图抵抗这次进攻。他在波尔多之外的加龙河畔迎战阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼的军队，结果是奥多遭遇了彻底的毁灭性失败。我们有一份
Martel and the kind of the Franks to the north, North of the Loire. The nightmare for Odo is the arrival of the Saracens, as he calls them. He is sandwiched between these two terrifying enemies. So he's got the Frankish kingdom to the north and he's got the Saracens who are kind of riding up from the south. And so unsurprisingly, Odo tries to kind of play these two kind of menacing enemies off against one another. Unsurprisingly, Odo tries to kind of play these two kind of menacing enemies off against one another. So in 721, the Ameyad forces, they've completed their conquest of the Visigothic stretches
由西班牙的一位匿名基督教牧师撰写的编年史。学者们称之为《754年编年史》（Chronicle of 754）。它基本上是我们了解当时情况的主要来源、最当代的来源。他关于这场战役记录道，奥多的军队在溃逃中被打得七零八落，“只有上帝才知道死去或被杀的人数是多少”。所以这对奥多来说太糟糕了。他在这场战役中幸存下来，但他肯定会担心阿基坦已经彻底失守了。因此，他召集了在这场灾难中幸存下来的部队，
of Ghul. And so then they turn their attentions to Aquitaine. And the spring of 721, they lay siege to the greater city in Aquitaine, which is Toulouse. And Odo turns to Charmatel and he says, look, we're all Franks together. Can you come and help me? This is a nightmare. And Charmatel, far from rallying to the cause of Christendom, he says, no, I'm interested. You're on your own. So poor Odo has to kind of basically deal with this crisis under his own agency.
从他的公国边缘地带招募了更多能找到的人，然后带着他们向北骑马前往卢瓦尔河，进入了由查理·马特统治的土地，来到了法兰克公爵这位他的死对头面前——这对他是极大的羞辱，但他别无选择——并向他乞求援助。而查理仍然在艰难地讨价还价。这并不是说他觉得，好吧，面对这个可怕的威胁，我们大家都是基督徒。
And he does it very, very effectively because he gathers his forces together. He approaches the besieging Arabs around Toulouse by stealth and he takes them completely by surprise and he wipes them out. And this is the first great defeat suffered by the Ameyad forces in Europe. And Odo is absolutely triumphant. He writes a letter to the Pope saying, I'm absolutely brilliant. I've killed 375,000 Saracens, which is possibly an exaggeration. But clearly it is a crucial victory. For the moment, he has saved Aquitaine from invasion. And he's won a breathing space, not just for himself, but also for Char Martel up in the northern lands, basically to prepare for the storm
你知道，他进行了非常艰难的讨价还价。他要求奥多向他臣服，承认他是奥多的上级，而奥多别无选择。于是他不情愿地表示了臣服。与此同时，在阿基坦，阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼的手下赢得了这场伟大的胜利，他们急于从中获取所有可能的利益。因此，他们蜂拥至阿基坦各地，扑向城镇，扑向修道院，将它们洗劫一空，把一辆辆大车装满战利品，然后向北隆隆驶去。你知道的，军队顺着通往卢瓦尔河的罗马道路涌去，装满黄金和宝藏的马车伴随着他们。他们向北走得越远，就越接近由法兰克公爵兼亲王查理·马特统治的土地。而
that they know is going to come. They know the storm clouds of war are gathering and so both men prepare for the invasion that is coming. And they know this because even though the the Yemeids have been defeated before the walls of Toulouse, they have not been expelled from Gaul. And they are launching raids all the time northwards as far as Burgundy, right? Right. So Otun in Burgundy, which Brunhild in the final years of her regency had made her capital, a kind of very beautiful ancient Roman city, that gets put to the torch. Lots of other towns do particularly monasteries. You compare the Arab Vedas to the Vikings for the same reason. They target monasteries because they're full of kind
我认为对于倭马亚军队来说，有一种明确的感觉，即他们正在冒险进入未知的领土。这里距离托莱多已经非常非常遥远，更不用说非洲了。他们对查理·马特知之甚少。他们对查理统治的人民知之甚少。他们对于前方可能有什么等待着他们并没有太多的概念。但当然，有一件事是他们时刻保持警惕的，那就是对战利品的渴望。同样，在这方面，他们就像维京人一样。当然，他们离卢瓦尔河越近，听到的谣言就越多——不仅仅是一个富有的圣地，而是一个极其富有的圣地，整个高卢最富有的圣地，里面充满了各种各样的宝藏。
of riches that can be carted off. And so this is looking really bad. So Odo, his strategy is to try and kind of pick Arab warlords off and enter into an alliance with them. And he succeeds in doing this with a Berber warlord called Uthman, who has been given the command of what today is Catalonia. So for the Aemaeids, it's a kind of border region, a marcher region. And Odo wants to stabilise his southern frontier and Uthman wants to carve Catalonia out as
有大量的财富可以被掠夺。所以这情况看起来真的很糟糕。因此，奥多他的策略是试图拉拢阿拉伯军阀并与他们结盟。他成功地与一个名叫奥斯曼的柏柏尔军阀达成了这一点，奥斯曼被委任指挥今天所谓的加泰罗尼亚地区。所以对倭马亚王朝来说，这是一个边境地区，一个边区。奥多想要稳定他的南部边境，而奥斯曼则想把加泰罗尼亚开辟为
a kind of independent fiefdom. He wants to rule it under his own steam rather than in subordination to the Aemaeid governor in Toledo. And the alliance is signed in 730 and to seal it, Odo gives Uthman his daughter in marriage. Can I just stop you right there? So a lot of listeners may find that really interesting because that obviously undermines the idea that this sort of titanic clash of civilizations and that people are consciously engaged in a clash of civilisations because here you have an alliance between Christian and, in a vertical way, Muslim and a marriage alliance along with that. So there's no sense that they've crossed some kind of tremendous ideological divide in doing that.
一种独立的封地。他想靠自己的力量统治它，而不是臣服于托莱多的倭马亚总督。这个同盟在730年签署，为了使之巩固，奥多将自己的女儿嫁给了奥斯曼。我能就在这里打断你一下吗？所以很多听众可能会觉得这非常有趣，因为这显然削弱了那种所谓泰坦式的文明冲突的观点，即人们是有意识地卷入文明冲突的，因为在这里，你看到了基督徒和穆斯林之间垂直的联盟，以及随之而来的联姻。所以在这样做的时候，他们并没有觉得跨越了什么巨大的意识形态鸿沟。
No, because what matters to both men, Odo and Uthman, is power politics. That's much more important than any sense of a kind of titanic clash of civilizations. And to begin with, it seems to work. There is stability along the line of the Aquitanian border. Uthman is able to establish himself as independent, but trouble is brewing. The storm clouds of war continue to gather because back in Toledo, the news of this alliance goes down like a cup of cold sick. And unfortunately for both Uthman and Odo, the governor in Toledo, he's a new governor, is exceedingly able and also exceedingly devout. And this is a man called Abd al-Rahman al-Ghafiqi. He is from Arabia. He's from the Red Sea. He comes from the heartlands of Islam. He probably far more than most people in Spain is completely on top of what is
没有，因为对奥多和奥斯曼这两个人来说，最重要的是强权政治。这比任何所谓泰坦式文明冲突的概念要重要得多。起初，这似乎起作用了。阿基坦边境沿线恢复了稳定。奥斯曼得以确立自己的独立地位，但麻烦正在酝酿。战争的阴云继续聚集，因为回到托莱多，关于这个同盟的消息就像是一杯冷呕吐物一样让人难以下咽。对奥斯曼和奥多不幸的是，托莱多的总督是一位新总督，极其能干而且也极其虔诚。这个人名叫阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼·加菲基。他来自阿拉伯。他来自红海。他来自伊斯兰教的核心地带。与西班牙的大多数人相比，他可能对正在形成的伊斯兰教有着更彻底的了解，他绝对不会容忍这一点。
becoming Islam and he is not prepared to put up with this. So his response is completely devastating. 731, he invades Catalonia. He defeats Uthman, has him killed, captures Uthman's wife, who is the daughter of Odo and packs her off to Damascus to live in the caliphate Harim there. So, you know, that's bad news for Odo and indeed probably for Odo's daughter. And you were saying that there's no real sense of a kind of clash of civilizations going on. While Abdulrahman is doing this in Catalonia,
所以他的回应是极其毁灭性的。731年，他入侵加泰罗尼亚。他击败了奥斯曼，将其杀死，俘虏了奥斯的妻子即奥多的女儿，并把她打包送到大马士革，住在那里哈里发后宫里。所以，你知道，这对奥多来说是个坏消息，对奥多的女儿来说大概也是如此。你刚才说这并没有真正感受到文明冲突的发生。正当阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼在加泰罗尼亚这样做的时候，
Charles Martel is signally not helping the Christian cause because he has crossed the Loire and is taking advantage of Odo's state of despair at the collapse of his alliance by launching an attack on Aquitaine and carting off loads of loot northwards to the Loire. So that's not helpful at all. Then the following year in spring, Abd al-Rahman invades Aquitaine. He sweeps northwards through Gascony, he descends on Bordeaux, he captures it, he sacks it. Odo has been frantically marshalling men to try and resist this attack. He meets the army of Abd al-Rahman on the banks of the Garonne beyond Bordeaux and the result is a completely devastating defeat for Odo. And we have a
查理·马特显然没有在帮助基督教事业，因为他已经跨过了卢瓦尔河，正利用奥多因联盟崩塌而陷入绝望的状态，对阿基坦发动进攻，并把大量的战利品向北掠夺到卢瓦尔河。所以这完全没有帮助。然后在第二年的春天，阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼入侵阿基坦。他向北横扫加斯科尼，突袭波尔多，攻占了它，并洗劫了它。奥多一直在拼命召集人马以试图抵抗这次进攻。他在波尔多以外加龙河畔遇到了阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼的军队，结果是奥多遭到彻底毁灭性的惨败。我们有一本
chronicle that was written by an anonymous Christian priest back in Spain. It's called the Chronicle of 754 by scholars. And it's essentially our main source, our most contemporary source for what's going on. And he records of this battle that Odo's army was scattered into flight and only God could know the number of those who died or was slain. So this is terrible for Odo. and only God could know the number of those who died or were slain. So this is terrible for Odo. He survives the battle, but essentially he must fear that Aquitaine is lost. So he musters what troops have survived the disaster,
由西班牙的一位匿名基督教神士编写的编年史。学者们称之为754年编年史。它基本上是我们主要的资料，是我们关于当时发生事情的最当代的记录。他关于这场战役记载道，奥多的军队四散逃窜，只有上帝才知道死者或被杀者的数量。所以这对奥多来说太可怕了。只有上帝才知道死者或被杀者的数量。所以这对奥多来说太可怕了。他在战役中幸存下来，但基本上他必须担心阿基坦已经失去了。因此，他召集了在这场灾难中幸存下来的军队，
recruits what more he can from the kind of the outer reaches of his duchy, and then he rides with them northwards to the Loire and crosses into the lands that are ruled by Charles Martel and he comes to the Duke of the Franks and his great rival humiliating for him but he has no choice and he begs him for assistance. And Charles is still driving a hard bargain. It's not as though he feels, well, we're all Christians together in the face of this terrible threat.
从他公国的最外围地区尽可能多地招募士兵，然后带着他们向北骑马前往卢瓦尔河，进入查理·马特统治的土地，并来到法兰克公爵他的死敌面前，这对他来说虽然很屈辱，但他别无选择，只能向他乞求援助。而查理仍然在讨价还价。这并不是说他觉得，在面对这个可怕的威胁时，我们大家都是基督徒。
You know, he drives a really hard bargain. He demands that Odo submit to him, that he acknowledge him as Odo Superior and Odo has no choice. So reluctantly, he gives his submission. Meanwhile, back in Aquitaine, Abdulrahman's men, they've won this great victory and they are keen to profit from it all that they can. So they are spilling out across Aquitaine, they're falling on towns, they're falling on monasteries, they're stripping them bare, they're loading wagons high with loot and they rumble northwards. You know the army spilling up the Roman roads that lead towards the Loire, the wagons full of gold and treasure accompanying them. And the further north they go, the closer they come to the lands ruled by the Duke and Prince of the Franks, Charles Martel. And
你知道，他真的在讨价还价。他要求奥多向他臣服，承认他是奥多的上级，而奥多别无选择。所以他不情愿地表示臣服。与此同时，在阿基坦，阿卜杜勒·拉赫曼的手下赢得了这场伟大的胜利，他们热切地希望从中获得尽可能多的利益。因此，他们涌入阿基坦各地，攻占城镇，袭击修道院，将其洗劫一空，将一车又一车的战利品装满，向北轰隆隆地前进。你知道军队沿着通往卢瓦尔河的罗马道路涌出，满载黄金和宝藏的马车伴随着他们。他们向北走得越远，就越接近法兰克公爵和亲王查理·马特统治的土地。而
I think for the Maid forces, there's a definite sense that they're venturing into unknown territory here. It's a long, long way from Toledo, let alone from Africa. They don't know much about Charmantel. They don't know much about the people that he rules. They don't really have a sense of what might lay ahead. But there is one thing, of course, that they are alert to, and that is the prospect of plunder. And again, in this, they are like the Vikings. And of course, the nearer they head to the Loire, the more they are picking up the rumors of, I mean, not just a wealthy shrine, but a fabulously wealthy shrine, the wealthiest shrine in the whole of Gaul, rich in every kind of treasure.
我认为对于倭马亚军队来说，有一种明确的感觉，即他们正在这里冒险进入未知的领土。离托莱多很远很远，更不用说非洲了。他们对查理·马特知之甚少。他们对受他统治的人民知之甚少。他们真的不知道前方会发生什么。但当然有一件事是他们保持警惕的，那就是对掠夺的期望。同样，在这方面，他们就像维京人一样。当然，他们离卢瓦尔河越近，听到的传言就越多，不仅仅是一个富裕的圣地，而是一个极其富裕的圣地，整个高卢最富裕的圣地，拥有各种宝藏。
And this shrine, of course, is the shrine of Saint Martin of Tours, the great patron saint of the Merovingian monarchy, but also more generally of the Franks themselves. And there is no way that the Duke of the Franks can possibly allow the invaders, if he can in any way help it, to strip the shrine of St. Martin Bear. Okay, so what will happen? Will they strip it bare? Will there be a great battle? Who knows? Come back after the break and find out. Anyone knows how powerful urges can be, it's me. Catch Dexter Morgan in a new serial killer origin story. Hunger inside of you, it needs a master. Featuring Patrick Gibson, Kristen Slater,
special guest star Sarah Michelle Geller with Patrick Dency and Michael C. Hall as Dexter's inner voice. I wasn't born a killer, I was made. Dexter Original Sin, new series now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus, a mountain of entertainment. Trying to escape the holiday playlist. Well, it's not gonna happen here.
Ditch the season for a vacation, Fa la la la la, la la la la. Leave the cold for a sunny location, Fa la la la la, la la la la. Ditch the mittens, grab the lotion, Fa la la la la, la la la la. Put Sunwing's Seasons savings on now, why not ditch the cold and dive straight into sun? Visit your local travel agent or sunwing.ca.
You know what's great about ambition? You can't see it. Some things look ambitious, but looks can be deceiving. For example, a runner could be training for a marathon, or they could be late for the bus. You never know. Ambition is on the inside. So that road trip bucket list? Get after it. Drive your ambition.
Mitsubishi Motors. Tsubishi Motors In this year, two comets appeared around the sun, striking great terror into those that saw them. One went before the sun, rising in the morning. The other followed it, sinking in the evening, as if foreboding dire calamity for east as well as West. Certainly one anticipated the day's beginning and the other the night's, so that they might act as a sign that evils threatened mortals at both times. They bore a fiery torch to the north as if to start a fire. They appeared in the month of January and remained for nearly two weeks. At that time a very serious plague of Saracens plundered the Gauls with miserable slaughter.
So that was the Venerable Bede writing in the Ecclesiastical History of the English People. Now Bede, not brilliant at dates to be fair to him, he said this happened in 729. He's pretty good. He's the guy who comes up with our dating system. He's at least three years out here. Probably. So he dated the Comets to 729, but there wasn't any Saracen invasion of Gorn in 729. Most scholars think he's got in a muddle and he's actually talking about 732. Yeah. Which is a bit odd because he actually claimed that he finished his book a year earlier. So maybe he put this in afterwards. I think that's probably the generally held theory. And if he did that, then it's witnessed to the fact that his sense that this is an amazing episode, it's something that's worth recording.
And also it bears witness to the fact that the news of this great battle that's been fought, this great Saracen invasion has kind of crossed the channel. It's spread up all the way through England up to Northumbria. So this is something that really resonates. And if Bede is writing about this invasion of 732, then this is the earliest witness that we have to it. And it is indeed very dramatic. It's not surprising that Bede, who's kind of obviously very tuned to the flow of great events, would have heard of it and been interested in it, because we have two great and formidable generals coming up against one another. So, Abd al-Rahman, the Umayyad general, the governor of Spain, I mean, he's already proved himself very, very formidable in battle. He's overthrown Uthman, he's defeated Odo, he's now heading
northwards towards the line of the Loire. We don't know how large his invasion force is, but it's evidently, you know, I mean, it's large enough to have defeated Uthman, to have swatted aside Odo. And it is also much, much better equipped than the Frankish army. I mean, I always remember I had a children's book of history that had an illustration of the Battle of Tours, and the Franks in that were kind of knights on armour and the Arabs all had you know they were kind of loosely you know wearing their kind of flowing robes. They were a Saladin in the Ladybird books. Yes, exactly.
But actually it's the other way round. It's the Omeid forces that are very much heavier in cavalry than the Franks and they're also much much better equipped. So a quote Bernard S. Bachrach, whose book on early Carolingian warfare is brilliant on this whole campaign, and he writes that the Arabs had acquired by conquest the arms manufacturing infrastructure of what had been a large part of the eastern half of the Roman Empire. These production resources were far better developed than those found during the early eighth century throughout the empire's Romano-German successor states in the west.
So basically, their kit is loads, loads better. And also the Ameids, they're just much richer. They've had a century and more of plunder behind them. They can afford better armor, better helmets, better swords than the Franks have. And on top of that, they're also much more technologically advanced. So there's one key technological development that the Franks can't rival. And again, to quote Bachrach, Finally, the Muslims had the technology to construct the composite recurve bow,
which was made from various layers of bone, horn and wood. These weapons were far superior to the wood and self bows available to the northerners. In addition, the shorter and more powerful recurve bow could be used effectively by mounted troops." And I read that because I don't really know what a recurve bow is. I was about to say it's one where the limbs of the bow kind of curve away. So it's a sort of more elaborate curve. So they kind of curl back on themselves like a horn almost. It's the kind you get in the Arabian Nights. Yeah, Arabian Nights kind of bow and even because of that, because of the extra sort
of tension or whatever, you can have a shorter bow. So in other words, it's easier to fire when you're on horseback. And also apparently it can go further than the Frankish bows can. So it's basically a brilliant bow. It's a great bow. It's a top bow. So basically, you know, this is not a kind of rag-tag desert army. This is a very, very formidable force and one that effectively is a kind of worthy successor to the Roman armies because it's drawing on those traditions. Now, people who've listened to the first two episodes will remember that the Franks too
are drawing on a Roman inheritance. So they were trained to fight in a Roman way. And that's a tradition that's endured for the two centuries since the fall of the Roman Empire in the West. And on top of that, they have Roman military manuals, which we know that they read. So like the Romans, they have an emphasis on infantry. At this point, the Franks do not have the kind of the heavily armored loricati they're called, the kind of the armored horsemen that are the precursors of the Western Knight. They are very, very much focused on fighting on foot. I think in part, although I gather that this is hugely debated by military historians, because they haven't yet adopted the stirrup.
The stirrup is just kind of being introduced to the land of the Franks at this point. So Charles would have had horsemen with him, and these were called palatini, so people who are, you know, his elites who surround him in the palace. And this is where the word paladins comes from, which is kind of very King Arthur. Lancelot and Gawain are the paladins of King Arthur. So he does have some of them, but the main focus is on, as I say, on infantry and specifically the Franks fight in a phalanx. So like the Romans had done, very close order, shields locked together. If they are faced by archers, as the Romans had done, they're able to kind of form a
testudo, a tortoise. So you put the shields up and over your heads and the arrows just kind of bounce off your shields and they fight so closely together that there's a Frankish report of a battle that was fought a century before the Battle of Tor that describes how the slain had nowhere to fall but stood in their battle lines, corpse supporting corpse as though they were still alive. So very, very close formation. So it's a bit like the images of fighting that you get in Bernard Cornwell's books, which are again not a massively dissimilar period. People packed in a bit like the images of fighting that you get in Bernard Cornwell's books,
which are again not massively dissimilar period. People packed in a kind of shield wall, stabbing with their swords relentlessly through the gaps in the enemy line. Yeah, the use of the stabbing sword rather than the slashing sword. And I guess people would associate kind of Frankish knights as using a massive, great, heavy slashing sword. But at this point, again, they are using the gladius as the Romans called it, the kind of the stabbing sword.
So they approximate to a Roman Legion more than to anything else. And of course, Roman Legions were dependent on relentless training. And this seems to have been what Charles had given his troops. So, you know, that breathing space, the Odo's defeat of the Arabs before the Wars of Toulouse had brought Charles. He doesn't seem to have wasted it. He seems to have essentially put his troops through their paces, drilling them and drilling them and drilling them. And even if his men are not as well equipped as the Ameyad forces, they are as well trained. And I think that this is what Charles is relying on to defeat them.
So those are the armies. What about the strategy of the two commanders? So Abdulrahman strategy is very plain. He wants to sack the shrine of St. Martin, and there are various reasons why he would be particularly keen to do that. The obvious one is loads of his troops are following him in the expectation of loot. Most of them, I suspect, are not motivated by a passionate commitment to the teachings of the Quran. They want to get as rich as they possibly can. And St. Martin's shrine promises them all kinds of goodies.
I think Abdul Rahman recognises the kind of significance to Frankish prestige of the Shrine of St. Martin. If he can sack it, it'll be a real body blow to the prestige of Shah Martel and his regime. And I think we've said Abdulrahman, he comes from the heartlands of Islam. He definitely has a kind of a doctrinal motivation. He wants to strip the shrine of St. Martin Bear, not just because it's full of treasure, but because as he sees it, it's full of kind of idols. He wants to humble the pride of the cross worshipers into the dust. But to do that, to reach the shrine of St. Martin, you know, he's going to have to wipe
out the army of the Franks, Charles's army. And the reason for that is that Charles's strategy essentially is to block his access to Tor and force him to attempt a decisive battle. And this for Abdurrahman is going to be a real challenge because even though his men are superior in kit and in military technology, the Franks, as we've said, are at least as well trained and they're also probably numerically superior. And that's because Charles's forces have been swelled by the troops that Odo has brought with him from Aquitaine. And of course, they are absolutely resolute in their determination to defend St. Martin's Shrine, just as Abdul Rahman wants to strip it because it's so precious to the Franks. Obviously, for that reason, the Franks are determined to defend and protect it.
Charles is confident that this is a potentially winning strategy because he can rely on his men to hold their ground, not to break, not to flee, but also, should the Arabs be defeated, not to run after them, you know, which would potentially then open them up to attack by the Arab cavalry. So this strategy effectively means the late autumn of 732 that a battle is going to be inevitable. Charles is going to block the road to Tor. Abdulrahman is going to have to engage him if he wants to break through. And the reason for that, he can't really retreat because that would be very damaging to his prestige and also if he retreats there's a risk to his baggage train with all that kind
of gold and stuff. So effectively there is no choice but to engage. So there's essentially a kind of week of shadow boxing and then finally the moment comes. The Arabs are on the Roman road, they see the Franks lined up ahead of them. There is no choice now but to engage in battle. And again, the best account of what happens is this Chronicle of 754 and the Christian priest writing that. He describes the Frankish battle
line in incredibly memorable way. The Northern has held their position like a glacier from the frozen North. I mean, amazing description. Kind of impassable, immovable, indomitable. But also icy cold and dangerous. He describes how the stabbing swords of the Franks, the gladi, inflict terrible damage on the invaders and among the dead is Abd al-Rahman himself. So again, the chronicle of 754. The Austracians, so that's the Franks, with a terrible strength in their limbs and an iron hand
throughout the hard fight killed him when they found him. And as evening comes, it's clear that the victory is the Franks. But what is perhaps the most impressive witness to their discipline is that they hold their line. I mean, as I said, it's the only way that they could have lost at this point would be if they'd kind of go, woo, we've won, brilliant, and piled off. They don't. They hold their positions and then they retreat to their camp pretty confident that the next day they're going to have to fight again, that the battle will continue. And I'll describe what then happens and what they find when they wake up the day after this first engagement by quoting the Chronicle
of 754. So this priest writes, rising from their sleeping bags at dawn, the Europeans, and it's such an interesting use of that. I mean, I think it's the first use of that phrase in any medieval chronicle. The Europeans beheld the tents and camps of the Arabs' canopies located and ordered as they had been, not knowing that they were all empty and supposing that the Saracens' phalanxes were prepared for battle within, they sent scouts and found that all the Ishmaelites columns had escaped, so that's the Arab columns, and that all of them were secretly fleeing home, passing the night in tight formation. The Europeans were anxious lest they might have concealed themselves on a hidden path as a stratagem. Stunned in every way, they hunted
the surrounding area in vain. Making no further effort to find the aforesaid people, they returned to their own countries rejoicing with their booty and the evenly divided spoils. So that's it. The invaders, the raiders have been beaten off and they've vanished with their stuff because they don't want to lose their... what plan do they have? I think they leave some of it behind and this is what the Franks pick up. But the Franks don't pursue them. I mean, that's what's striking. They let them go. Right. And it's indisputably for them a great victory. St. Martin is safe.
St. Martin is safe and his shrine will never be threatened again. But this leaves open the question that we began this episode with. Yeah. What is the significance of this battle? Yeah. You know, is it world historical in its moment? Is it world historical in its moment? And I guess the first question is, what do we make of this attack that the Ameyad forces
have launched on the Loire? Is it a raid? Is it a maneuver in a kind of factional battle between assorted Christian and Muslim warlords? Is it a Muslim attempt to humble a Christian shrine? I reckon the answer to that is that it's all of those. I mean, they're not mutually exclusive. You know, the desire for loot, the ambition that Abdulrahman had to punish the treachery of Uthman and to kind of humble Odo into the dust, his zeal for Islam.
I mean, all of these are clearly part of the mix of motivations, I think, that are encouraging him. But what it isn't is a long planned, cold blooded, coordinated, massive invasion. No. It's not that. It isn't. But I think that doesn't mean that it's not significant. Let's do a counterfactual.
Abdurrahman wins. Yeah. Charles Martel is killed. Odo is killed. They march on the shrine of St. Martin. They strip it bare, and then they cart all the treasure back. And what happens next? You know, we can never be sure in any of these situations, you know, there are so many kind of intangibles, but the balance
of probability would be that Aquitaine would definitely fall to the Ameid forces. I mean, if Odo is dead, if his men have been wiped out, there's no real prospect of the Ameid forces not occupying it and kind of making it a forward base beyond the Pyrenees. The one thing I would say is if they have that, they have to keep supplying it with men and whatnot from beyond the Pyrenees, which does look like a pretty significant natural barrier through most of history between France and Spain. They do, but then the Straits of Gibraltar are also a pretty significant barrier and they've managed to take Spain. And I think part of the reason for
that is that success attracts followers and there would undoubtedly have been people in Aquitaine who would have wanted to side with the winners. that would have then have provided a kind of reserve of manpower that the Aemaeid occupiers could have drawn on. And if they do that, then the consequences of that for southern Gaul are pretty clear. I mean, southern Gaul will become part of the Aemaeid caliphate and that in turn, I think, would have put Italy in peril. And Italy, of course, is the home of the Papacy in Rome. And the Byzantine forces there are, you know, under attack. You've made a massive leap in the course of a sentence from they'd probably got aquatain
to suddenly Italy has fallen as well. Like your dominoes are falling very quickly. Well, if Southern Gaul falls, then the Franks can't come to the rescue of the Papacy. And as we will see in our next episode, essentially in this century, the Papacy is dependent for its political survival on Frankish support. So I think it's improbable that the Papacy that Rome would have held out against Muslim domination had Tours gone the other way. And the implications of that would have been pretty significant. I mean, what about the implications for the independent Frankish kingdom? I mean, it's got huge reserves of manpower. It could easily have rallied. It could have held out. It could have launched a reconquest of the South.
That after all is what, you know, in in the long run the Spanish Christians do over the course of the middle ages. But I think that there are two episodes from early medieval history that suggests that it would have been a challenge, it would have been difficult for the Franks to do that. And the first of course is what we've just been talking about the defeat of the Visigoths. Because if you say you know the attack on Tor was just a raid, well essentially the invasion across the Straits of Gibraltar into Spain was just a raid. But because the invaders won this massive battle and killed the Visigothic King within a decade, pretty much the whole of Spain had fallen into their lap. And, you know, with Aquitaine as a base, I think the potential for a kind of campaigns of jihad against the Franks in the North would
have been considerable, which isn't to say that the same thing would have happened, but it might have done. We don't know. But the other event that I think, you know, had the Shrine of St. Martin been sacked, there is then an obvious parallel later in the century, which you alluded to right at the beginning of this episode. And that's what the Vikings do when they launch their campaigns against, particularly England. And that begins with the sack of a they launch their campaigns against particularly England. And that begins with the sack of a famous shrine, the Shrine of St Cuthbert on Holy Island, the island of Lindisfarne. And what that demonstrates is that to loot a shrine that has a kind of a special holiness is never just to loot it because as well as the financial loss, there is also the shock
that it delivers to people for whom this shrine is a kind of central part of their spiritual identity. So the sack of the shrine of St Cuthbert on Lindisfarne sends shock waves not just across Britain, but across the whole of Europe. And I think it gives a pretty devastating blow to Northumbria morale and the Kingdom of Northumbria falls to pieces fairly soon afterwards. And I think that the sack of the Shrine of St Martin would have had probably an even greater impact. St Martin is the great patron of Frankish royalty, but by the eighth century, it's
become much more than that. So St. Martin, he's the first, he's the most celebrated of all Gauls monks, of all Gauls holy men. And he has become the emblem of a kind of common identity that has joined Franks and Romans. They all share a kind of common devotion to this saint. And so you could say that the sack of St. Martin's Shrine would have been a blow not just to Frankish prestige, but to the very spiritual identity of this emergent Frankish nation. And of course, at the same time, it would have offered evidence for those with eyes to see of the truth of the message that is being proclaimed by the invaders. And it's absolutely true that this is not kind of at the forefront of the Umayyad campaign. It's not particularly what they are proclaiming.
And therefore very few people at the point where the Battle of Tours is being fought really have a sense of anything approximating to Islam. So this is why it's not couched by contemporary chroniclers as a great clash of civilizations or anything like that. So Bede, who we've referenced this, you know, the great scholar and historian writing in his monastery up in Northumbria, he has only the vaguer sense of who the Saracens, as he calls them, you know, vaguer sense of who they are. He thinks that they're pagans, that they're worshippers of the morning star. There are others who are closer to them, who think of them essentially as Christian heretics. Which is so common. That's what Christians think of them in the early years of Islam,
isn't it? Right. And I think right the way through to the Middle Ages, I mean, Dante is still kind of, you know, that's still how he's framing them. I mean, they don't really have a sense of Islam as a religion. I mean, that's a much later kind of conceptualization. And maybe because of that, maybe because Islam in some ways is very close to Christianity, you know, Jesus is in the Quran, Virgin Mary's in Quran, both Christianity and Islam have a respect for the Hebrew prophets. That is a big difference, I think, between the Muslim invaders of Spain and Gaul and the Vikings, because there are doubtless people in England who do end up
abandoning their Christianity and turning to the worship of the Viking gods. But it's not a sophisticated framework of belief and the kind of structures of imperialism that the Vikings bring are, you know, it's basically kind of grab it and settle and that's at the limit of it. But the evidence of Muslim Spain shows that Islam is very, very different, that it has a very sophisticated relationship to Christianity. It has a framework for subordinating Christians and Jews and kind of, you know, putting them within an empire. The Quran mandates how they should be taxed, how they should be subordinated, all these kinds of things. It's a program for imperial rule. And that is an obvious point of differentiation between the Vikings and the Arabs. And that's why Spain, it's not just that it is ruled by Muslims, it becomes Muslim over the course of the centuries
that follow its conquest. And I think you could suppose the Muslims hold on to southern Gaul. You could see the same process happening there. You know, that would have pretty seismic implications for the future course of medieval history. And I think ultimately to think that the annihilation of Charles Martel's army has no real significance, that it's just a raid, that it's nothing very important. And I think ultimately that to suppose that had Charles Martel lost the battle, had he died, had his troops been wiped out, had the Shrine of St. Martin been attacked, that it was just a raid. I think that to kind of believe that, it's effectively to argue that Islam
and Christianity and specifically the distinctive form of Christianity that emerges in Western Europe in the centuries after the Battle of Tours, that they're essentially the same, there's no real difference between them. It doesn't really matter if you're ruled by Christians or by Muslims. I just don't think that's true. I think that there is a very, very profound difference between the two ways of seeing the world. And so therefore I think that the Battle of Tours is significant. I mean, I don't think it's a kind of peripheral clash. I think it is momentous, perhaps not quite as momentous as Gibbon suggested, but pretty important. And Charles Martel's victory in that sense is pretty seismic in the long run, but it's seismic also in the short term because it has very important implications for the future of the Frankish kingdom and for his own dynasty. Are there not some other reasons why you could question the idea about the momentousness of this battle? So for example, Umayyad Chronicles often mentioned big defeats.
So they mentioned defeats in the early stages of the Reconquista, for example, but they never mentioned this at all. Like it doesn't even feature. They treat it as a raid that just, you know, just one raid among many and beaten back. I looked this up, there were more raids in 734, there was a raid in 736, and there was actually some people think an even bigger raid, even bigger invasion in 739, when the Umayyads got to Burgundy, only to be beaten back by the Franks. So in other words, this was not the end of their incursions. So in that sense, it's not really a turning point. It doesn't change anything because they just keep coming.
I think it is for reasons that we'll look at in the next episode, because it means it's not just the Franks have won, Charles Martel has won, but kind of the glory of his victory kind of resonates to his prestige. And as we will see, he is now in a position, not just to defend his kingdom against the invaders, but to go on the offensive. And his son in turn will be able to do that. And his grandson, who is Charlemagne, will definitely be able to do that. But there's one other thing which is even more important, which I think is arguably much more important than the Battle of Tours, and that's in 740. A huge revolt breaks out in what's now Morocco, Great Berber Revolt, and that basically cuts off Umayyad Spain from the sort of Arab heartland.
It means that the age of raiding kind of comes to an end because they can't keep raising all the, you know, there's so much internal dissension and the Emirates can't keep raising all these Berber troops. So that would seem to undermine the idea that, oh, they get aquatane, then they get this, then they get this, then they get this, because actually they've got so many problems in their own kind of backyard, as it were, that they were actually never going to be able to do all that because of the massive ructions going on in North Africa. No, I don't think so, because what also then happens after that is that, and we've did this in our history of Baghdad, is that the Ameids are overthrown by the Abbasids.
But one of the Ameids is able to get to Spain where he establishes himself as its ruler and in the long term as its caliph. And this is the great golden age of Ameid Spain. And it's ferociously and impressively formidable. It's a very potent military power and it's a very great kind of civilizational power. And this is the period when you see large numbers of Christian Spaniards converting to Islam because it has this kind of great force of appeal. It's culturally, militarily, politically,
more appealing than Christianity, which seems a kind of defeated and superseded way of seeing the world, way of explaining man's relationship to God. And had that realm that the Ameyads take over in the wake of the Abbasid Revolution. Had that extended to Southern Gaul, had it extended to Northern Italy, then that would have been an even larger power base for the Umayyad Caliphate. All right, well, if people want to listen to that, they've got an episode on Umayyad Spain,
which I greatly recommend. But for the time being, we're gonna be going on with the story of the Franks, right, Tom? So what's coming up next? So coming up next, it's the son of Charles Martel and his relationship with the Papacy, which is again a development of seismic impact for the future history of Europe and therefore
我非常推荐。但目前，我们将继续讲述法兰克人的故事，对吧，汤姆？接下来会讲什么呢？接下来是查理·马特的儿子以及他与教宗的关系，这同样对欧洲乃至未来的历史具有震撼性的深远影响，因此
in the long run, the world. And this man, Pippin, who overthrows the Merovingians makes himself king. He is the father of a much greater and more famous king, Charlemagne. And so at the end of our next episode, Charlemagne will be entering the story. Brilliant. So next up is our Charlemagne trilogy, one of the most epic stories we've ever done on The Rest is History. Now, the good news, if you remember The Rest is History Club, is that you should have all three parts of that trilogy right
从长远来看，也影响了全世界。这个人就是矮子丕平，他推翻了墨洛温王朝，自立为王。他是更伟大、更著名的国王查理曼的父亲。因此，在我们下一集的末尾，查理曼将登场。太棒了。所以接下来是我们的查理曼三部曲，这是我们在《历史的剩余》中做过的最具史诗感的故事之一。现在，如果你还记得“历史的剩余俱乐部”，好消息是你现在应该已经拥有了该三部曲的所有三部分
now. Now if you're not a member of the club and you'd like to get your hands on them, all you need to do is head to therestishistory.com and sign up and you can have that Charlemagne trilogy straight away. If not, I'm afraid you'll just have to wait. See you then. Bye bye. Bye bye. Bye bye. Hello everybody, Dominic Sandbrook here. And I'm Tom Holland. And we have some incredibly exciting news to tell you, don't we Dominic? We do.
。如果你还不是俱乐部会员，想要获取它们，你只需前往 therestishistory.com 并注册，即可立即收听查理曼三部曲。如果不是的话，恐怕你只能耐心等待了。到时候见。再见。再见。再见。大家好，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。我是汤姆·霍兰。我们有一个极其激动人心的消息要告诉大家，对吧，多米尼克？确实如此。
So we often say we've got exciting news, but this is genuinely very, very exciting news. We are thrilled to announce that after the sellout show that we did earlier this year, The Rest is History will be returning to the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday, the 4th of May to perform live once again with an orchestra. And we will be bringing you a brand new show and this time discussing two more of history's most extraordinary, fascinating and iconic classical composers, in this case Tchaikovsky and Wagner. And these extraordinary lives will be brought to life thanks to the accompaniment of the renowned Philharmonia Orchestra conducted by the celebrated Oliver Zefferman.
所以我们经常说我们有激动人心的消息，但这绝对是极其、极其激动人心的消息。我们非常高兴地宣布，继今年早些时候场场爆满的演出之后，《历史的剩余》将于 5 月 4 日星期日重返皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅，再次携手管弦乐团进行现场演出。我们将为您带来一场全新的演出，这一次我们要讨论的是历史上另外两位最非凡、最迷人、最具标志性的古典音乐家，他们就是柴可夫斯基和瓦格纳。这些传奇的人生将在著名指挥家奥利弗·泽费曼执棒的知名爱乐乐团的伴奏下生动地呈现在大家面前。
So that first show that we did this year was a truly glorious experience and we are hoping that this too will be an unforgettable night. There'll be great music, we'll be telling great stories, we'll be delving into the history. So you had better get your hands on tickets for the show as soon as you can. And these tickets will be available from www.royalalberthall.com on Thursday, the 19th of December with a presale for the Rest is History Club members and Royal Albert Hall friends and patrons 24 hours earlier on Wednesday the 18th of December at 10am. That is the Rest is History live with the Philharmonia Orchestra, Tchaikovsky and Wagner. It's at the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday the 4th of May. Now the tickets are available for members on Wednesday the 18th of December and for
今年我们举办的第一场演出是一次真正的绝妙体验，我们希望这一次也将是一个难忘的夜晚。这里有美妙的音乐，我们会讲述精彩的故事，我们还将深入探讨历史。所以你最好尽快抢购这场演出的门票。门票将于 12 月 19 日星期四在 www.royalalberthall.com 上发售，“历史的剩余俱乐部”会员以及皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的朋友和赞助人可于 24 小时前的 12 月 18 日星期三上午 10 点提前优先购票。这就是《历史的剩余》携手爱乐乐团带来的现场演出，主角是柴可夫斯基和瓦格纳。演出将于 5 月 4 日星期日举行，地点在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅。现在，会员门票将于 12 月 18 日星期三开售，而
the general public on Thursday the 19th of December and please make sure that you don't miss it. If the history buff in your life is always regaling you with the same old facts about Churchill or Napoleon, why not get him or her, and let's face it you, a present? After all, Christmas is just around the corner and a very happy coincidence, our first official Rest His History book is now out as the perfect stocking sized paperback. It is packed to the brim with the most bizarre historical questions you never thought to ask like what was the most disastrous party in history?
公众门票将于 12 月 19 日星期四开售，请千万不要错过。如果你生活中的历史迷总是向你滔滔不绝地讲述关于丘吉尔或拿破仑的老生常谈，为什么不送他（或她，咱们说实话其实就是送你自己）一份礼物呢？毕竟，圣诞节即将来临，非常巧合的是，我们第一本官方《历史的剩余》图书现已出版，作为完美的口袋尺寸平装书。里面塞满了你从未想过要问的最离奇的历史问题，比如历史上最灾难性的派对是什么？
Which British politician plotted to feed his lover to an alligator, and why was a Brazilian emperor mistaken for a banana? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哪个英国政治家密谋将他的情妇喂给短吻鳄，以及为什么一个巴西皇帝会被误认为是一根香蕉？本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。